التقرير الاخير لمعهد ستوكهولم الدوليه
لابحاث السلام والمعروف باسم سيبري كشف عن
تراجع الانفاق العالميه على التسلح في
الفتره ما بين 2018 و2022 مقارنه بالسنوات
الخمس السابقه كما كشف ايضا عن زياده
بنسبه 74% في واردات السلاح الى اوروبا
وبينما تصدرت الولايات المتحده قائمه
الدول المصدره للاسلحه على مستوى العالم
جاءت روسيا في المرتبه الثانيه هذا رغم
التراجع الذي حدث لصادراتها العسكريه فيما
تحاول فرنسا تعزيز مكانتها بين الدول
المصدره للاسلحه ونجحت بالفعل في تقليص
الفارق بينها وبين روسيا لمناقشه اهم ما
كشفوا تقرير المعهد الدولي لابحاث السلام
عن صادرات وكذلك واردات الاسلحه حول
العالم وايضا توجهات الدول في الانفاق
الدفاعيه انضموا الينا من الباحث الاول في
برنامج انتقال الاسلحه في معهد سيبري
السيد
اولا مصر ويزمان اهلا بك معنا في عسكري
تيريا يعني بالرغم الحرب في اوكرانيا
احتفظت روسيا بمكانتها هي الدوله الثانيه
على مستوى العالم في مجال تصدير الاسلحه
هل هذا يعني بان سمعه السلاح الروسي لم
تتاثر حتى هذه اللحظه بسبب الحرب والى اي
مدى تعتقد بانه سيكون هناك تاثير سواء
ايجابي او سلبي على سمعه السلاح الروسي في
المستقبل
سمعتهم لم تعد كما كانت والارقام الموجوده
في الدراسه مبنيه على مده خمس سنوات لكن
ان نظرنا للسنوات الثلاث الماضيه التي تلت
فتره السنوات الخمس تجد ان صادرات السلاح
الروسي اقل بكثير اذ تعاني روسيا العديد
من المشكلات فيما يتعلق بتصدير السلاح
حاليا كما ان هناك عقوبات مفروضه عليها من
دول الغرب ما يجعل انتاج السلاح اكثر
صعوبه على روسيا كما يتعرض المشترون
المحتملون والحاليون للسلاح الروسي لضغط
لعدم الشراء وهذا الضغط من الاوروبيين
وكذلك امريكا ناهيك عن الحرب نفسها
والدروس المستفاده من هذه الحرب وهي ان
السلاح الروسيه لا يبدو على درجه جيده من
الكفاءه كما ان صناعه السلاح في روسيا
مشغوله حاليا لانتاج السلاح لاستخدامها
الخاص ما يترك صناعه السلاح للتصدير تفتقر
للوقت وفي السنه المقبله المشهد تراجعا
اضافيا على صادرات السلاح الروسي مصر
وزمان فرنسا نجحت يعني طبقا للتقرير في
معهد استقال الى انها تقلص الفارق ما
بينها وبين روسيا وتحاول ان تصل الى
المرتبه الثانيه في قائمه الدول المصدره
هل تعتقد بانه فرنسا ستنجح في هذا الامر
وما هو الانعكاس الاستراتيجي لهذا الامر
سواء بالنسبه لفرنسا او بالنسبه لاوروبا
حققت فرنسا نجاحات ملحوظه في السنوات
الاخيره خاصه في بيع طائراتها المقاتله
التي لم يكن عليها طلب في السابق وفي
الوقت ذاته تتراجع مبيعات روسيا وبالتالي
ستتساويان قريبا وكما نعلم من طلبات
الشراء الحاليه نجد ان فرنسا لديها طلبات
تفوق بكثير الطلبات من روسيا لذلك اتوقع
ان فرنسا ستتجاوز روسيا خلال نحو ثلاث
سنوات لتصبح ثاني اكبر دوله مصدره للسلاح
اي تتقدم فرنسا وتتراجع روسيا
يعني التقرير كشف كذلك عن تراجع في مبيعات
الاسلحه الصينيه وايضا البريطانيه في حين
انه كشف عن قفزه هائله في مبيعات كوريا
الجنوبيه وكذلك الايطاليه اولا ما هي
اسباب تراجع المبيعات الصينيه وكذلك
البريطانيه وما هي اسباب ارتفاع مبيعات
الاسلحه سواء من كوريا الجنوبيه او من
ايطاليا على الجانب الاخر يعني
بعض هذه الانماط تحدث بالصدفه خاصه
بالنسبه للدول غير المصنفه على قائمه اكبر
مصدري السلاح سوريا الجنوبيه مثيره
للاهتمام هنا لانها تمكنت خلال العقود
الثلاثه الماضيه من تطوير صناعه السلاح
لتكون قادره على التصميم والانتاج وروجت
كوريا لذلك وتمكنت من تحقيق نجاح مبهر ليس
فقط في الدول الناميه التي كانت تستهدفها
في البدايه بل ايضا في دول متقدمه ومؤخرا
في عام 2022 تلقت كوريا طلبا ضخما من
بولندا ما يشير الى ان كوريا الجنوبيه
ستواصل تطورها كدوله مصدره للسلاح فمنتجات
كوريا متقدمه الى حد كبير ولديها الرغبه
في التصدير وتقديم الدعم للصادرات من خلال
البيع بالائتمان ومن الواضح ان الحكومه
وراء هذا القطع وليس لديها اي شيء ضده بل
تدعمه بشكل كامل وهناك اسواق كثيره اداء
كوريا فيها ممتاز لان السعر معقول وسيجل
هم من حيث الدعم الفني مهم جدا وقوي وهذا
مبني الى حد على نجاح كوريا في القطاع
المدني اذ تتميز المنتجات المدنيه الكوريه
بجودتها والدعم الفني لها جيد وهذا ينطبق
ايضا على السلاح
مصر سجلت المرتبه الثالثه في مشتريات
الاسلحه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط طبقا
للتقرير لكن لمن كانت الحصه الاكبر هل
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ام لروسيا
وكذلك ما هو ما هي توقعاتكم بالنسبه
لمشتريات وتوجه الانفاق العسكري في مصر
خلال السنوات القادمه
[موسيقى]
في السنوات الاخيره روسيا وفرنسا كانت من
اهم موردي السلاح لمصر وواصلت امريكا
مكانتها كما لدينا ايطاليا التي حصلت على
طلبات كبيره وكذلك المانيا اما كيف سيكون
الوضع في المستقبل القريب حسب ما ارى
ستكون روسيا خارج هذه الدائره فقد كانت
هناك صفقه لشراء طائره روسيه مقاتله لكن
الصفقه تم الغائها العام الماضي والسبب هو
الضغط الامريكي على مصر كي لا تمضي بهذه
الصفقه والا فسيكون لذلك تبعات هذه
الطائره ذاتها يتم بيعها حاليا لايران لكن
هناك دول اخرى ظهرت ولديها الرغبه بتزويد
مصر بالسلاح ومصر لديها الرغبه بالشراء
منهم كوريا الجنوبيه وقعت صفقه كبيره مع
مصر لذا ارى اننا سنشهد زياده في الدوري
الكوري في السنوات المقبله كما توجد طلبات
من فرنسا ومصر لا تزال تبحث عن اسلحه اخرى
من متنوعه مثل الاوروبيين وكوريا وربما
تركيا وبالتاكيد من امريكا لان ما تحصل
عليه مصر من امريكا هو بتمويل امريكي عبر
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه وهذا امر
مفيد في كل الاحوال مصر على خلاف كل
التوقعات شهدت منطقه الشرق الاوسط تراجع
في الانفاق الدفاعي اولا برايك ما هي
اسباب هذا التراجع وهل هذا الامر له علاقه
بمساله اهتمام دول او بعض دول المنطقه
بتوطين الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه وكذلك
كيف تقيم اصلا تجربه بعض دول الشرق الاوسط
في توطين الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه
بداخلها
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد توطين
الصنه للسلاح ليس في العالم العربي فحسب
بل في مناطق اخرى ايضا لكن لم تكن ناجحه
بشكل حقيقي في العالم العربي حتى وقت قريب
اذ بدانا نرى دولا مثل الامارات تدخل في
تصنيع سلاحها الوطني وتصميمه بمساعده من
الخارج وبعناصر مستورده لكنها في النهايه
تصميم اماراتي السعوديه كذلك اطلقت
برنامجا للانتاج والتصميم المحليا مصر
ايضا تعود الى هذا المسار هناك الكثير من
التحرك في هذا المجال لكن الى اي مدى يمكن
لهذه التجارب ان تنجح هذا امر يصعب ان
نعرفه السلاح البسيط وحتى الضخم منه لا
يصعب انتاجه لكن عندما ياتي الامر للسلاح
الاكثر كلفه والاكثر تقدما وقوه ستواجه
الدول مشكله وجود التكنولوجيا ووجود
اقتصاد قوي ليغطي التكاليف وهذا يحتاج
وقتا كثيرا كما نرى على سبيل المثال في
دول مثل الهند التي ما غير قادره على
اداره الانتاج رغم مرور 50 عاما مصر وزمان
الحرب في اوكرانيا لها تداعيات كبيره على
مشتريات السلاح في الوقت الحالي في القاره
الاوروبيه لكن ما هي اكثر المنظومات التي
يوجد عليها اقبال حاليا من قبل دول القاره
الاوروبيه وكذلك الى اي مدى الشركات سواء
في اوروبا او في الولايات المتحده قادره
على تلبيه هذا الكم المتنامي من الطلب
اعتقد اننا على المدى البعيد الى حد ما
ستكون هناك قدره على تلبيه الطلب لكن
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وانهم يحتاجون السلاح
اليوم وليس غدا هنا تكون المساله صعبه لان
خطوط الانتاج محدوده فلننظر الى امور
بسيطه مثل الذخيره حيث تستنفذ اوكرانيا
الالاف منها يوميا وتعداد استهلاكها
السنوي بالملايين خطوط الانتاج في امريكا
واوروبا ليست مصممه حاليا لانتاج هذه
الكميات في وقت قصير سيكونون
مستعدين خلال عام او اثنين فالمساله لا
تتعلق بالتصميم بل اقامه مصانع جديده وهذه
ليست اكبر مشكلاته
عند
البحث الاول في معهد استوكه لابحاث السلام
في برنامج انتقال الاسلحه السيد شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا